je voulais vous parler du rat taupe ne
le rates obtenu c'est une petite souris
qui vient en afrique de l'est en somalie
ethiopie kenya et cette petite souris
elle a une caractéristique elle vit 30
ans en bonne santé alors qu'une souris
d'habitude sa vie deux à trois ans
maximum
c'est comme si nous humains on vivait
600 ans en bonne santé
alors elle fait jamais de cancer jamais
les d'équivalent d'alzheimer jamais de
lundi cardiovasculaires la peau reste
intacte sexualité fertilité un tacle
aucun signe de vieillissement
on a essayé de lui implanter des tumeurs
cancéreuses violente elle rejette tout
de suite des artères reste intacte
parfaite
le système neurologique le cerveau tout
jeune et ça c'est un modèle formidable
parce que sera obtenue détient la clé à
la fois du vieillissement qui là ne
paraît pas inéluctable et en même temps
la clé d'une longévité en bonne santé
elles résistent sera obtenue cette
petite souris à tout ce qui va nous tuer
un jour on est à l'omh de faire des
progrès absolument formidable en
médecine des progrès à couper le souffle
laissez une souche pour réparer et
reconstruire complètement des organes on
va faire un bond en avant spectaculaire
et je considère que à partir de
maintenant toutes mort avant 120 ans est
une mort prématurée
alors comment faire pour tenir le temps
que les secours arrivent
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire à ce moment
là alors je vais vous parler d'abord des
télomères l'été le maire qu'est ce que
c'est c'est des petits manchots kona au
bout des chromosomes de chacune de nos
cellules
plus ils sont longs plus on vit
longtemps en bonne santé
plus ils sont courts plus on meurt
rapidement de cancers alzheimer ou
maladies cardiovasculaires voyez c'est
comme un peu des boues en plastique là
cette chose dessus de l'a7 chaussures
autrement dit si je bouffais une prise
de sang maintenant pour connaître la
longueur de voter le maire je n'aurais
pas votre âge chronologique mais votre
âge biologique
autrement dit le temps qui vous reste à
vivre on va pas le faire parce que sinon
vous allez penser je rachetais en viager
vos maisons ça serait pas bien alors
c'est très sérieux les télomères c'était
compensé en 2009 par trois prix nobel de
médecine
donc ce robuste c'est fiable mais la
bonne nouvelle dont on s'est aperçu sait
qu'on peut les rallonger le destin
n'apparaît pas inéluctable en dix mois
si on modifie notre mode de vie
on les rallonges et ça c'est quelque
chose de formidable
alors je vais vous expliquer maintenant
comment vous pouvez faire pour avoir de
beaux télomères on dit pas t'as d'beaux
yeux tu sais mais ta beauté le maire tu
sais alors premièrement pour avoir des
baux télomères les rallonger exercices
physiques quotidiens 30 minutes
d'exercice physique par jour sans
s'arrêter
10 minutes de 40 % les risques en serre
alzheimer maladies cardiovasculaires et
en plus on fait une décharge
d'endorphines c'est du bien-être
attention j'ai 10 ans arrêtée parce que
les vingt premières minutes on brûle du
sucre ça sert à rien à partir de la
vingtième minute on va brûler des
mauvaises graisses on libère 1004
molécules protectrice et là on a tout
l'effet bénéfique de
donc ceux qui font du golfe ou qui
marche un petit peu dans marseille à
droite à gauche sert à rien du tout
c'est un petit complément pour le
principe mais c'est pas là que ça se
joue donc tous les jours surtout je veux
dire à partir de 40 ans est un vrai
champ de tir
on voit des maladies dans tous les sens
ce qui arrive savard se protéger s'il ya
une chose à faire rien qui vont me dire
oui mais je fais du sport le week-end je
vous le redis vous laver les dents que
le week end aussi essentiel joué mais
j'ai pas le temps du tout je suis
débordée attendait au lieu de regarder
la télé avachi sur un canapé ou passer
des coups de téléphone à 6 achetez-vous
à vélo d'appartement hefetz en même
temps si vous gardez ce principe vous
avez un vrai bouclier par rapport à
énormément de problèmes de santé discret
incluait ça dans votre routine ça
augmentera la longueur de vos télomères
et vous gagnerez des années de vie en
bonne santé
en plus vous conserverez votre potentiel
musculaire parce que après trente ans on
perd 1 2% de muscles par an c'est quand
même mieux
le deuxième élément c'est la nutrition
une pression est essentielle vous avez
30 % de calories en moins c'est 20% de
vie en plus essentielle cette nutrition
surtout quand on sait qu'un enfant de 7
ans aujourd'hui à consommer aux rondes
sucre que son grand père durant toute sa
vie dont il faut s'alimenter alors c'est
compliqué parce que 95% des régimes
échoue donc ça marche pas très bien et
en même temps il faut perdre du poids
surtout qu'une enquête récente a montré
que la moitié des français sont en excès
de poids
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à ce
moment-là faut bien agir média pas de
médicaments qui marche
il ya plein de petites rues car je serai
pas le temps de tout ce que voulait dire
aujourd'hui
j'aime bien les coupe faim naturel parce
que c'est des coupes-faim puissant
prenez deux cheveux ou deux carrés de
chocolat noir 100% vous verrez sa chute
la ghréline nord l'hormone de l'appétit
ça marche très bien
prenez attendait 5 minutes au milieu
d'un plat ou avant d'en reprendre au
lieu de vous arrêter de manger parce que
l'estomac va exploser et bien vous allez
stimuler le centre de la satiété dans le
cerveau et là vous arrêterez
naturellement aux récents vous ai fait
cette expérience
quand on attend trop longtemps un plat
ou le dessert on a pu en vie on a
stimulé son centre de la société ou
alors on est près de la mer prenez des
sardines 3 sardines ces 250 calories
mais ça fait partie des aliments retard
ça reste 9 heures dans l'estomac
on n'a pas faim on grignote pas c'est
comme un peu de cannelle sur des pommes
ça ralentit aussi la vidange gastrique
ya plein de petits trucs formidables qui
existe qui vous permettent de garder un
poids de forme tout au long de l'année
vous avez à chaque seconde on produit 20
millions de cellules pour remplacer nos
cellules usées ou mortes à chaque
seconde et le problème qu'on a c'est que
plus on avance en âge
le nombre d'erreurs de copies augmente
essai erreur de copie
ça donne des cancers par exemple bien on
s'aperçut que si on prend des souris on
les fait je n'ai simplement un jour par
semaine 20 % de cancer en moins tout de
suite chez les humains avec 12 à 16
heures de jeûne en buvant bien sûr de
l'eau des tisanes du thé ce que vous
voulez si ya pas de contre indication du
médecin traitant 12 16 heures c'est pas
c'est pas beaucoup
le teint plus clair plus tonique - das
moins d'énergie moins de rhumatismes en
fait depuis le début de l'humanité on
sait faire face aux manques mais pas à
l'excès d'ailleurs toutes les religions
de la planète parle de jeunes un moment
donné comme un message du fondane eu des
temps pour réactiver mémoires
biologiques anciennes faites le test
vous verrez vous par exemple
demain vous sauter le petit déjeuner
vous buvez beaucoup vous verrez comment
vous sentez mais notre problème c'est
palm ans c'est vraiment alex est un
autre sujet c'est le sommeil bien sûr
sept à huit heures de sommeil c'est
important
trop c'est pas bon pas assez c'est pas
bon les médicaments je suis tout à fait
opposé parce que ça ne donne pas semer
récupérateur alors il ya plein de petits
trucs naturel pour bien dormir un
premier par exemple c'est tout
simplement le noir complet ne laissez
pas une petite diode dans la chambre ça
casse en qualité en quantité de sommeil
et là on va pas être bien du tout si
vous pouvez le noir complet vous ne
l'avez pas mettez un masque tout
simplement d'avion et vous dormirez
comme des bébés le cerveau aussi demande
est stimulée c'est très important
vous savez en trois semaines de vacances
on perd 20 points de quotient
intellectuel je vous dédie pas l'état
d'un cerveau quand quelqu'un part en
retraite c'est assez ça va pas du tout
donc si vous voulez que votre cerveau
soit en permanence
de plus en plus performants et se soit
pas une déclinaison fait des choses
nouvelles si tous ensemble on nous fait
une irm aujourd'hui on mesure notre
cerveau et pendant trois mois
on va décider d' apprendre à jongler au
bout de trois mois
quand on our fans hier m une nouvelle
zone du cerveau ce sera fort mais on
aura augmenté notre capacité à prôner
des langues étrangères
nouvelle visite et des pays casser les
habitudes casser les routines et votre
cerveau en apprenant des choses que vous
n'avez jamais fait sera de plus en plus
performants et en même temps quand tu as
un cerveau qui fonctionne bien on est
beaucoup plus heureux et le bonheur est
très important aussi
il ya aussi des choses sympathiques ce
pour augmenter ces télomères la
sexualité douze rapports sexuels par
mois augmente de 10 ans l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé
donc j'espère que ce week end va être
utile
c'est important parce que cette
sexualité bon en tant que médecin on a
aucun tabou
elle fait partie de l' équilibre de la
bonne santé tant pour les hommes que
pour les femmes et en plus quand on a
ces douze rapports par mois on fait dix
ans de moins et quand on paraît dix ans
de moins
on vit dix ans de plus c'est tout bon un
petit conseil en passant pour la
sexualité beaucoup ont des sexualités
qui sont pas terribles des manques
d'orgasme haut niveau féminin au niveau
masculin des érections pas terrible en
fait le périnée c'est un petit muscle
qui en entre l'anus et le vagin chez la
femme l'anus et les bourses chez l'homme
et ce petit must ou faible doit
supporter les 30 kg environ qui sont
dans le tronc il ya un moment donné bien
faiblard quand il bien faiblard avec
simplement trois minutes d'exercice par
jour
on repère le périnée vous êtes en train
de faire pipi vous arrêter en plein
milieu vous l'avais repéré reproduisent
et ses contractions trois minutes par
jour très simple et bien du côté féminin
plus d'orgasmes ça évite les petites
fuites urinaires qui a parfois
intempestives et chez l'homme des
affectations ferme stable un bon
contrôle de l'éjaculation est un
excellent tang la direction donc pendant
que je continue à parler vous pouvez
déjà commencer à vous entraîner
personne ne s'en doutera donc
quand je vous dis que vous allez passer
un bon week-end vous voyez c'est bien
parti
donc c'est très important de développer
justement ça parce qu'en plus ça donne
de la joie de vivre on sait que les
optimistes font des vieux zoo par
rapport aux pessimistes
le dernier poisson aussi l'hygiène est
importante parce que l'hygiène apporte
justement une façon d'éviter les états
inflammatoires pour rien du tout il faut
se protéger aussi des pesticides qui
attaquent aussi alors des gestes simples
vous avez une pomme est plus celle à 90%
de pesticides en moins tout simple si on
vous présente une viande un poisson une
pizza x et noir 3 cm de croûtes brûlé
c'est comme fumer 200 cigarettes c'est
cancérigène donc simplement par une
série de petits gestes très simples on
peut arriver à se débarrasser de pas mal
de produits chimiques de produits
toxiques simplement en agissant et aussi
les médicaments beau c'est vrai que j'ai
fait j'écris un livre qui s'appelle le
meilleur médicament c'est vous ces
terres que jean prescrit en tant que
médecin mais le moins possible on
parlait des somnifères j'préfère les
éviter en france on est dans un pays de
houle ya la moitié des gens constipé ou
prennent des laxatifs megan des petits
gestes simples btm petit tabouret en
face aux toilettes
tiens un autre exercice que pourrait
fermer tout seul en fait la position sur
le trône n'est pas du tout physiologique
lors de la new rectal est fermé c'est
pas bon du tout c'est comme un tuyau
plein d'eau qui est pliée qui arrive pas
à se vider
et bien si vous vous montez vos jambes
sur un petit tabouret vous ouvrez langue
l'anneau rectal et les étude a montré
que les gens gagnent une heure par
semaine et en plus ils ont un ventre
plat donc vous voyez on peut s'amuser
avec son corps il existe au plus profond
de l'être humain des moyens d'auto
guérison extrêmement puissant il suffit
de les activer
pour en bénéficier pour se protéger de
nombreuses maladies et aussi souvent
guérir
on a un potentiel formidable en ou
d'auto réparation
le dernier prix nobel de médecine qui
étaient attribués sur l'autophagie monde
qu'on a ces facultés d'auto guérison
l'autophagie c'est un peu le une cure
détox de nos cellules qu'elles se font
elles mêmes et on peut les stimuler il
ya certains aliments il stimule
autrement dit on à magnifique potentiel
en nous et en suivant un mode de vie
agréable vous l'avez vue est différent
on peut réellement atteindre que tout
mort avant 120 ans sera une mort
prématurée
je vous remercie